sandy alamar jr will manage today terry
francona
has uh an intestinal issue it's not
coveted related so we wish to hear
the very best we're looking at tyler
clipper who has made 12 starts
in his career mostly in relief here
later in his career and we've seen a
pitch
very very well and the 2-2 pitch he got
him strike three
and there's the split so clifford
strikes out his former teammate
two down and now lindor one hop line
drive right side
from the sheller right field grass
louisa dies fields and throws out the
runner
at 11 pitch one two three first did it
the indians send aaron savali to the
mound no score in the first max
kepler leading it off and the 1-1 pitch
line to right towards the corner that
ball
will land fair kepler's gonna round
second
and he will make third easily great
start lead off triple max kepler to
begin the day
domingo santana is saying that ball was
out of play
that it bounced up and then bounced back
into play
the indians are challenging it their
ball call was made
and then did the ball leave the field of
play
yes and they'll move him him being max
kepler to second base with a double
here's jorge polanco the switch header
manning left-handed
and the 3-1 pitch is carved back of
third that's going to land softly base
hit here comes kepler rounding third
and he will score standing a weekly hit
ball but landing in a perfect
spot left field shallow near the line an
rbi
single kepler is in one-nothing twins
seventh pitch of this at-bat to the
twins catcher
from the wind-up and the 3-2 pitch a
drive to left field and deep
back it goes deep it goes and gone
there's number one for garber
ah kind of a get off my back home run
for the silver slugger
and the twins take a two-nothing lead it
was 85
outer half but garber got the barrel
going forward and
pulled it with power out to left center
so the twins have a runner at second
cruz struck out his first time up and
the pitch a line drive smash up middle
base hit center field
mex around third he will score and cruz
knocks in kepler from second base
a two-out rbi single and it's a
three-nothing twins lead
holding a second is hernandez here's
francisco lindor
swung on line left field down the line
and it bounces one hop off the wall
on it quickly as rosario as hernandez
will score
heading for second is lindor good throw
by rosario and lindor's out
the indians get a run but a perfect
strike from the left field corner out
number two
he played that off the wall masterfully
and then a strike to polanco who caught
it turned around
beggar partner rise caught it and he was
waiting for the head first lighting
lindor to greet his glove
3-1 minnesota aaron sivali
has struck out nine minnesota batters
and there are two down for eddie rosario
swung on popped up
foul ball third base side ramirez
through the coaching box
makes the catch and aaron savali he
gives the indians six
solid innings the indians bottom third
of the order coming up
trevor may is the new pitcher for
minnesota
fastball and he took it straight three
and so trevor may
just continues the parade of twins
dominant pitching oscar mercado two
fly-outs
and it is swung on banged on the ground
wide of third and it got by adrianza
adrianza took a couple of steps to his
left or towards second
and that ball somehow just did tick the
outer edge
of his glove daniel johnson was in the
on deck circle but now
that you have the tying run to the plate
the ambience are going to go
with front meal race the old two he got
him strike three on a breaking ball
so may got ahead and then went to a
slider
and reyes on three pitches strikes out
for the second out here in the eighth
inning
and now hernandez a double a walk in a
run officially one for two as switch
hitting second baseman
strike three called painted the outside
corner with the hard stuff
hernandez didn't like it may strikes out
the side
three to one nelson came through with a
two out rbi
single in the third scoring kepler now
he has gonzales at second polanco at
first and the 3-2
pitch is striking recalled he went off
speed and cruz
is out number three sergio romo trying
to finish off cleveland today
romo off for the fourth time he has
saved one three innings no runs
a hit he has fan four the 3-2 this one's
popped up should be playable back up
short
rosario out battling the sun andre yanza
will make the catch
with a squeeze in left field he had two
defenders going out rosario doing a
somersault at the end to avoid contact
but adrianza made that play one out
two down santana oh for two of the walk
here's the pitch he got him strike three
called on a change changeup
and for the first time since 2001 the
minnesota twins begin
a season 7-2